brain controlled robot arm in four years
and pokemons Ekans backwards is snake
Auerbach is Cobra and Buck backwards is
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow
okay so Kinect tax let you control your
TV with your hands but the NES actually
had a controller called the you force
that allowed you to control Mario and
Rio with your hands in 1989
unfortunately it didn't work very well
that's why they say don't touch you
might have seen this street-legal Tron
light-cycle hey this is neat stuff but
what's really neat is this giant curved
oh le d-- screen it's the next
advancement in flexible screen
technology bendy some old-school
technology becomes new with this modded
NES DVD player and check out these
custom NES paint jobs they even have
windows on the top to see what game is
locked and loaded here's a Nintendo
hologram from the 3ds launch that might
be the only thing cooler to have in your
bedroom that level one one of Super
Mario Brothers
[Music]
this is world seven of Super Mario 3
check out the islands and crowbar plus
armed equals half life how about a
slow-motion world this is HD video taken
with a phantom Flex high-speed cinema
camera that kind of looks like month
hey are you textin my front door lock oh
cool literature and 8-bit graphics
collide with the Great Gatsby game I'm
not sure if you could write a book
report on the game instead of reading
the book but it's really fun to play
find the link below and it begs the
question what's your favorite book that
you read in school if you have one
finally let's check out a cinematic
tribute to the Neo Geo
I'm going to leave you with a riddle the
first person to get the real right and
explained how they got their answer will
be featured at the top of the sauces
channel page as our genius
of the week
[Music]
Mary walks into a hardware store to buy
something for her house when asked the
price the clerk says the price of two is
fourteen cents the price of thirty five
is twenty eight cents and the price of
two hundred thirty-five is forty two
cents
what does Mary want to buy think you
know it leave your answer in the
comments below and as always thanks for
watching